welcome everyone thank you for joining
us at the tissue based research
workflows virtual event our final
presentation for today is morphology
driven High Flex sexual analysis of
tissue environments presented by
Nicholas conforto my name is Serena and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is Interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
during the presentation
to ask a question click on the Q a box
located on the bottom of your screen
type your questions and hit submit
speaker will answer your questions
following the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the Q a
box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem
please join me in welcoming Nick for
complete biography on our speaker visit
the biography tab on the left Nick over
to you
hello everyone my name is Nick conforto
it's a pleasure to be here today I am
the senior director in charge of our
digital spatial profiling business unit
at nanastring Technologies and I'm here
to present on our geomix platform which
is our digital spatial profiler and how
it can be used to do morphology driven
High Plex spatial analysis of tissue
microenvironments
so for those who aren't familiar uh with
who who nanostring is uh we are based in
Seattle Washington we were founded in
2003 out of the institute for systems
biology uh and we developed all sorts of
different uh High Plex digital
Technologies
um that are mostly used for biomarker
Discovery and translational research
um so our first platform was our
encounter system which did bulk gene
expression analysis and then in 2019 we
added a spatial element to our portfolio
which was our geomix digital spatial
profiler which allowed us to now do this
morphology driven uh hypex analysis from
distinct regions of interest within
tissue conserving spatial information
um but the encounter system uh has well
over 700 uh boxes worldwide now
um we've been in a number of
Publications
um and and it's been used for
translational research
um as well as Discovery research uh to
look at predicted biomarkers in immuno
oncology and so uh we we partnered with
in 2017 we had partnered with Merck
um to evaluate the encounter platform uh
for doing bulk gene expression analysis
as a predictive tool for their uh
keytruda which is their um uh checkpoint
inhibitor therapy uh their pdl1 uh
anti-pd one checkpoint inhibitor therapy
um and in this in this publication uh we
compared uh bulk gene expression
analysis of an 18 Gene inflammatory
signature
um against uh their gold standard pdl1
IHC for its predictive power so did an
18 Gene we were we set out to understand
whether an 18 Gene inflammatory
signature which basically characterized
hot and cold tumors prior to receiving
checkpoint therapy could be a better
predictive tool
um than just the pdl1 IHC on its own and
what we found was these 18 Gene this 18
Gene signature these gene expression
signatures are actually really good
strong predictive tools for response to
this treatment
um and so in this in this publication
highlighting the power of these gene
expression signatures as predictive
tools
um and better than what was the gold
standard at the time
now as great as these gene expression
signatures have been and and
characterizing hot or inflamed and
non-inflamed tumors and enriching for a
population of patients that could
potentially benefit from a checkpoint
therapy
um there was still room for improvement
even on this biomarker signature
um so while all while uh cold tumors or
non-inflamed tumors rarely responded to
treatment not all highly inflamed tumors
um responded the same way so there were
some heterogeneity even within the
populations of the highly inflamed tumor
uh patient samples and so uh trying to
understand that underlying heterogeneity
trying to come up with better predictive
biomarkers
um was a was a mission of ours and and
obviously you know as much promise as
these uh as these new therapies have for
uh for curing and uh and and advancing
um tree treatment for cancer and
oncology
there's still a lot of room for
improvement and and you know as we as we
strive for uh better predictive tools
and precision medicine
um you know we're always looking for
better ways to approach this and and
understanding the underlying mechanisms
of response to treatment or or evasion
in some instances and so you know when
thinking about tumor biology and and why
maybe a bulk expression signature on its
own is not enough
we have to really understand you know
how the tumor works right so and how
these checkpoint therapies work so when
you've got an inhibitor therapy that's
removing the brakes from your immune
system to go in and fight the tumor
itself you need to make sure that that
tumor is primed and that inflammatory
signature
um gives you a good understanding of how
much how how what the presence of those
immune cells are within or around the
tumor but it doesn't necessarily tell
you whether or not those immune cells
are actually infiltrating directly
within the tumor itself so when we look
at um these two samples here and we
compare them on the left hand side your
both of these samples for example have
highly inflamed scores so that 18 Gene
inflammatory signature would be
considered high for both of these but
when we look at the sample on the left
what we're actually seeing is high
stroma contamination within the sample
we're seeing immune cells that are most
mostly present outside this of this of
the tumor regions uh and so those immune
cells aren't necessarily infiltrating
within the tumor and therefore may not
necessarily be uh as as
um as powerful once the uh once that
checkpoint inhibitor therapy is received
as compared to the sample on the right
where we see high infiltration of immune
cells directly within the tumor itself
uh and so you know you need spatial
tools to really start to understand
things like the tumor microenvironment
you know tumors are extremely
heterogeneous as we see here with these
two examples and so you know just doing
analysis at a level may not give you a
complete picture or the full story of
what's happening within your tumor
sample that you're interested in
profiling and so in this instance uh a
spatial tool is a requirement for really
understanding that uh intratumor and
interest sample heterogeneity
um so not just but now not just spatial
tools but also bulk tools that give you
all of that high Plex predictive power
of say our bulk gene expression
signatures but then also being able to
conserve that spatial information as
well and bring the two together
so
one of the challenges uh with with
spatial tools historically has been that
um that they're low plaques so doing an
IHC or even multiplexed
immunofluorescence in a lot of cases
requires lots and lots of sample because
of the low Plex nature of those
Technologies so if we want to get all of
this underlying biology or say we want
to look at those 18 genes but we want to
look at them spatially what we wind up
having to do is take multiple serial
sections of our precious clinical
samples to be able to get all of that
spatial information at that high of the
level and so when we're looking at you
know very precious clinical samples or
in the instances of trying to do some
reverse translation where we may have a
bank tissue samples and we're trying to
go back and reinvestigate uh you know a
past clinical study we may not have
enough sample available to us and and
not only that not only is it um you know
uh is it not a great use of this sample
that's available to us to be able to do
all of this
um but it also uh is is time consuming
and resource consuming it's obviously
obviously quite expensive to have to
take this many sections and stain them
all individually but then finally we're
also not getting all the combinatorial
information that could be gained by
doing all of this from a single tissue
section so ideally a perfect technology
out uh perfect technology for predictive
biomarker work especially in Reverse
translation where we've got Bank tissue
samples would be to get all of this
Multiplex data but get it all of it get
all of it from a single tissue section
where we can get all of that
combinatorial information uh together
from a single slide
and so I you know this has kind of been
the the Paradigm out there up to this
point where you know if you wanted
spatial information it was mostly low
Plex and really more qualitative in its
approach you know immunofluorescence as
great as it is and as much as we've made
strides in digital pathology there's
still a lot of work to be done to really
truly digitize uh a fluorescent which is
which is really kind of an analog
readout and make it a digital readout so
so you know explanation's historically
been low Plex not very quantitative
um and then you know counter that with
the high Plex quantitative you know
information that we can get from things
like our encounter platform uh or bulk
sequencing where we're losing the
spatial information so
what we want to be able to do is bring
the two of these Technologies together
and get a really good clear
understanding of what's happening within
these tissue microenvironments and
really understand what the underlying
mechanisms of both disease and our
potential therapies are
so what we've done with the geomix
system is we've really tried to build a
bridge between these two capabilities
and so this is an example data set of a
colorectal cancer that really shows you
how we're connecting uh the spatial uh
information from multiplexed
immunofluorescence with the quantitative
Digital Data of of say our encounter
system or an Illumina next-gen Next
Generation sequence there so in this
case both of the data sets that you're
seeing here both the fluorescence image
and the Digital Data have come off of
our geomix platform these are all from a
single ffpe tissue section and that
colorectal cancer what you're seeing is
we stain that section with pancit
keratin in purple and cd45 in green and
then what we want to do is directly
compare the microenvironment within the
tumor or say region 10 to the
microenvironment within say an immune
cell enriched region and that cd45
enriched region 7. and we want to be
able to conserve that heterogeneity
between those regions so we can see
what's happening
across a whole set of genes or proteins
within each of those distinct regions
and so that's the data that you're
seeing right on the right hand side
there that data is actually directly
comparing the expression analysis of
this handful of proteins in this
instance between that tumor enriched
region and that immune cell enriched
region and we're seeing that with that
Digital Data that you see there actual
digital counts of the amount of those
targets that are present within those
regions and we're conserving that
heterogeneity
um and and doing that all uh you know at
a very high Flex level
so let me talk through what I'll do now
is just kind of explain how this
technology Works we've designed the
geomix system our digital spatial
profiler to work with whatever tissue
samples our customers have available to
them in the lab so it's been tested on
Fresh Frozen
um obviously it's been tested and
validated for ffpe as I had just shown
but not just ffp and fresh frozen but
also all sorts of different
um tissue samples that you may have
access to whether they be core needle
biopsies you know ffp tissue blocks that
you have to section they could be
pre-mounted sections or even things like
tissue microarrays the system gives you
this flexibility to be able to select
your own regions for profiling and to
really work with whatever samples you
have available to you in the lab
foreign
once you have your samples uh what we're
doing is just using standard
immunohistochemistry or
immunofluorescence protocols for
staining or labeling those sections
those samples so you'll take a five
Micron tissue section you'll have it
mounted on your slide that section will
then you'll do all of your staining so
antigen retrieval staining all on that
single section and what we're going to
do is we're going to label that section
with a cocktail of probes and those can
be either antibodies for protein or in
C2 probes for mRNA so regardless of what
analyte type you're interested in
looking at the system is multi-omic so
allow you to look at both protein and
mRNA and we'll label up that section
with a cocktail of these probes and that
cocktail will include
um probes that have these little oligo
tags attached to them for uh profiling
and these are extremely high Plex so we
can go anywhere from you know 10 probes
all the way up to 20 000 probes
um so we have great uh Plex capability
built into this system for profiling and
that's what you'll get your digital
expression data from and then as you've
seen in that previous example we also
label up that section with some uh
fluorescently labeled probes as well for
doing the region of Interest selection
and for visualizing our tissue on the
system and so this the the system itself
has four fluorescent channels built into
it so we'll label up that section with
up to four fluorescently labeled probes
um for visualization
and all of that gets cocktailed together
on that section and then that section
goes on to the geomix system uh and is
ready for profiling I will point out the
uh the sample prep portion of the
protocol is automated so our partnership
with Leica allows us to do our antigen
retrieval and our staining now uh
completely automated on the Leica system
on the bond RX which allows for minimum
Hands-On time and obviously great
reproducibility as well from from user
to user
so once that section is labeled up with
all of those probes it will go on to the
geomix system I did mention it is a
multiomic technology so those probes uh
are antibodies for protein detection and
uh in C2 hybridization probes for uh
mRNA detection uh each probe has a photo
cleavable Linker attached to it and then
a synthetic DNA barcode so that barcode
is what we're actually reading out on so
once your tissue section is labeled uh
we use a UV illumination to release to
release that photo cleavable Linker and
then those oligo tags are released into
a a liquid that sits over top of the
tissue and then those oligo tags are
what are actually being read out
um for your Digital Data uh with the
platform so as I mentioned uh antibodies
for protein ish probes for mRNA uh
Protocols are standard uh ish protocols
or immunofluorescence protocols for
protein so
um can fit within a standard pathology
workflow uh and then once uh once your
tissues are labeled they go onto the
geomax platform and then the geomix
system will go through uh it will you'll
it'll scan the fluorescence of that
tissue section so you'll see your Four
Color fluorescence show up on the geomix
you'll then go through and select the
regions of the tissue that you're really
interested in profiling and there are
many different ways to do that which
I'll take you through in a few minutes
here but once you've selected your
regions on the tissue you hit run and
then the system goes through in an
automated fashion and it starts picking
from each region one at a time so what
it does is it moves the objective this
is a microscope so it moves the
objective over to the first region it
turns the UV light on that UV light then
releases those photo cleavable linkers
from all of the probes that happen to be
present just from that one region that
you selected
those probes then are released into that
liquid that sits over top of the um of
the tissue and then a micro capillary
system goes through and just starts
sipping up that liquid and then
dispenses it into a single well on a 96
wall micro tighter plate where each well
is actually mapped back to where it came
from on the tissue itself so we're
indexing each of those regions back to a
specific well on that plate that plate
comes off
each of those wells in that plate is
barcoded to each of those distinct
regions
uh that plate comes off and then it can
be read out those oligos are read out
either on our encounter platform for low
Plex High throughput use or it can be
read out on an illuminous sequencer for
higher Plex
um more kind of quantitative uh higher
Plex analysis
um so the system is able to work with
both encounter as well as aluminous
sequencing for the readout of those
oligo tags
uh that data that comes off of the
sequencer or this or the encounter then
gets fed back into the geomix system and
the software
and it links that Digital Data back to
this the fluorescent image and back to
those regions that you had selected uh
on the system so it allows you to really
directly connect expression analysis
back to those distinct spatial regions
within the tissue and then what you see
there is is that output on the right
hand side of your fluorescent image in
this case that's a tonsil section where
we stain that tonsil with a pan side of
keratin in purple uh CD3 uh uh in um in
yellow there and uh and then uh oh sorry
pancetta keratin and blue CD3 and purple
and uh and um cd20 in um in those yellow
regions and now what we're seeing is
distinct expression profiles for each of
those morphological regions within that
tissue section
so we you can imagine the power of this
of this system for doing biomarker
Discovery uh we've worked with a number
of pharmaceutical companies who've been
using this platform for doing biomarker
Discovery within their own Labs
um and one of those uh one of those
early partners with us on on developing
and using the system was Jansen research
and development in Spring House
Pennsylvania and so Josh Roosevelt is a
scientist on their translational
research team and the first thing he
wanted to do when he got his hands on on
the geomix system was to run a
concordance study he wanted to make sure
the data coming off the geomix matched
with what they were seeing
um with their IHC pathology scoring uh
on a number of samples in this case we
were highlighting five non-small cell
lung cancer tumors that they had
profiled with 12 regions of interest on
the geomix platform and they wanted to
compare their pathology scoring of high
medium and low within those samples to
what we were able to see digitally with
the geomix platform
and what we were able to find was the
the Digital Data matched up really
nicely with their pathology scoring and
in some instances you could see really
improved upon what they were able to do
with just the high medium and low
scoring with uh with pathology with the
pathologist I
um so it's a digital platform geomix you
can see the the large dynamic range that
we have here and so for these proteins
across these samples we saw really good
concordance and in some instances you
could see maybe where a pathologist's
eye would have a really hard time
differentiating between the high medium
and low with the geomic system we're
seeing all of the heterogeneity even
within those categories
um and so just giving you some
advancement over kind of what's been
done historically over you know almost a
century now of pathology work uh and
really bringing it to the digital age
so we've got uh it's it's great to be
able to do this kind of on these
geometric regions where we select kind
of a tumor region or in the case of you
know germinal centers or epithelial
layers
um you know on that tonsil section but
obviously there's a lot of heterogeneity
even within those geometric regions or
circles that you could select within the
system so how do we really get at some
of the phenotypic profiling that we want
to be able to look at within our tissue
samples in this case we're showing you
how we do this using a what we call a
digital micro mirror device or DMD chip
that's built into the system itself but
that DMD chip allows us to do is finely
control the UV light in little one
micron increments within the system so
those micro mirrors there's about a
million of these micro mirrors on this
little semiconductor chip each one of
those micro mirrors is individually
controllable with the software and it
allows us to finally control that UV
light so we can create what we call
these phenotypic masks in the system for
doing profiling so I'll give you an
example of what I mean here so this is a
colorectal cancer that you see in the
middle that's a pancetta keratin stain
in yellow for fluorescence and then
there's a DNA counter stain in purple
that you're seeing for nuclei
what we did was we have some image
analysis tools that are built into the
software that allows us to look at that
colorectal tissue
identify or set gating criteria for what
our tumor cells are in this case we're
saying tumor is anything that happens to
be pansytokeratin positive so we're
going to set a binary gating criteria
that says anything pan CK positive is
tumor and that creates that white
phenotypic mask that you see in the top
right hand corner there
we can then use that mask to control
that digital micro mirror to only shine
UV light on the white regions and not
the black regions of that masking that
you see so what allowed us to do is only
shine UV light on the tumor cells only
releasing the oligo tags the photo
cleavable linkers from the probes that
are bound to those tumor cells so it
allows us to profile our tumor region
exclusively and then since it's a binary
mask we can actually take the inverse of
that mask and look at everything around
the tumor so the micro environment
around the tumor and profile that as its
own separate region of Interest so what
this allows us to do is profile tumor
versus the tumor microenvironment
completely separately and really
understand the underlying heterogeneity
as well as the underlying biology within
those distinct regions of Interest
now as I mentioned this is built
directly into the system into the
software so in our um in our uh Suite
here of software you go through you'd
see your tissue section you'd select the
region that you want to profile you'd
set your gating criteria and then that
gating criteria which would create these
masks that you see here so in this
instance doing a tumor versus tumor
microenvironment mask you can see there
the the yellow and the blue are your two
distinct regions that will receive their
UV light independently
and then as we go through different
regions of the tissue once you've set
that gating criteria that gating
criteria will follow through to those
different regions as well so you don't
have to do that every time
so in this case this is also a
colorectal cancer that you see here CD3
in purple cd45 in blue and pan side
keratin and green
and then we selected some distinct
regions across the tissue and use that
masking capability to be able to
actually profile those regions
individually and so if we look at the uh
at the heat map here on the right hand
side we're actually seeing that that
masking is clustering the data based off
of those different unique masks so we
would expect the biology to be different
within those phenotypic compartments as
we're seeing here with the data but then
also seeing some clustering between
things like the invasive margins that we
selected the tumor centers as well as
even some normal colon that we selected
there in region 10. um so just showing
you the power of this technology not
only to look at like unique signatures
of expression across samples but also to
look at unique signatures of expression
even within a single sample
um and so you know I've highlighted two
of the two of the different ways we can
select regions within this platform it's
extremely flexible and allows you to ask
some really great unique questions of
your tissue samples
um so in the case of you know wanting to
look at geometric regions which could
just be circles or squares or polygons
um you know you could be asking what's
the heterogeneity of expression Within
These different you know just regions
you know geometric regions of my tissue
in the case of being able to do
segmentation you know which I had showed
previously you know you may want these
distinct uh morphological profiles that
you want to be able to look at like
tumor and tumor microenvironment we also
have this capability which we call cell
type specific profiling which allows you
to select specific cell types based off
of their fluorescent staining so we have
some studies we've done with folks like
Dr David Rim at Yale where he's looked
at phenotypic compartments of things
things like macrophages and lymphocytes
and tumor cells to look at distinct
expression profiles and signatures and
looking to see whether they're
predictive for response to things like
immune immunotherapies as well
um and then you know we've got the
capability to do things like Contour
profiling where we want to look at
expression gradients across a tissue
sample or if you're really just looking
for like uh in in a hypothesis free
manner if you want to just kind of grid
the tissue section we do have the
ability to just drop grids across your
tissue section as well and get kind of
an unbiased just overall look of the
expression across your tissue sample
without necessarily looking within
specific phenotypes or compartments
and I mentioned uh we I've shown you
some protein expression data previously
uh we also have the MRNA capability
built into this as well one of the nice
things about mRNA is your ability to
scale the Plex
um so we've gone up to uh I think I've
mentioned about 20 000 genes we can look
at with things like our whole
transcriptome Atlas assay that we
released this year we've also built some
really nice curated content specifically
for uh oncology called our cancer
transcriptome Atlas that's an 1800 Gene
panel that carries that's been curated
to look at things like the tumor biology
immune responses micro environments high
low and medium expressors all of this is
based off of
um tons and tons of Publications that
have been out there publishing on bulk
expression as well as single cell
expression of uh of of tumors and so
it's really good high curated content
um specifically if you're looking at
cancer biology but if you want to just
get an overarching look at you know the
entire transcriptome
um all you know protein encoding genes
we've built two whole transcriptome
Atlas assays one for human and one for
Mouse
um and uh and like I said those are the
entire protein coding transcriptome uh
and really great unbiased look at the
underlying biology of your tissue
samples and all done on a single ffpe
tissue section so as I mentioned both of
these have been tested and validated to
work both in ffpe as well as fresh
Frozen
um and uh and all on a single five
Micron tissue section
and you can imagine the power of things
like this once again for looking at
things like uh response to treatment or
prediction of response to treatment this
is from one of those such studies where
we were taking our regions of Interest
creating these tumor and tumor
microenvironment masks and then looking
at both protein and mRNA expression
within uh Within These distinct
compartments and in this instance
looking to see how the biology is
changing within that pan cytic keratin
enriched region uh or in in that
instance would be our tumor region so
both on treatment and off treatment
doing something like this volcano plot
that you see here that's showing you the
significance and differential expression
between samples that were profiled on
treatment and samples that were profiled
that were off treatment or uh that did
not receive treatment and looking to see
how that tumor region differs between
these two uh between these two sample
sets
I've mentioned uh we have our
partnership with Leica around automating
a sample prep we also I've also
mentioned our partnership with Illumina
for being able to read out view those
oligo tags on a little Lumina sequencer
that will work with their
um all all of the aluminum platforms
um we also have our partnership with ACD
so if you're not familiar with ACD they
have their RNA scope technology which is
a fish based technology for doing
immunofluorescence of RNA probes and so
the RNA scope will work on the same
sections that we can do our mRNA
profiling with so if you wanted to
for fluorescently uh visualizing your
tissue we do have the ability to work
with RNA scope as well we have a
partnership with abcam which gives us
access to over 6 000 of their antibodies
in their catalog fpm has one of the
largest antibody catalogs uh on the
planet and so having access to that
catalog for doing things like oligo
tagging as well as custom labeling of
antibodies in case there's a specific
antibody that you'd like to see that
maybe we don't include in one of our
panels you can work with app Cam and
they will help you custom label an
antibody from their catalog to include
in our assay
uh and then uh academic collaborations
and Partnerships as well uh we created
our geomix translational leadership
Network last year which allowed us to do
some collaborations around specific
things like breast cancer or covid-19
research
um we also have a partnership with the
human cell Atlas where we help support
some of their research so some of the
work that's being done for atlasing at
the single cell and spatial level
through through the HCA we have a
partnership
um with the Mayo Clinic and OHSU to
develop diagnostics for the geomic
system as well so while the platform
today is an ruo platform obviously you
can imagine with the digital and
Multiplex capability of this system and
as we push further and further towards
Precision medicine that a platform like
this could be applied in a more
regulated setting and so we're currently
exploring what the development of that
would look like with this partnership
with the Mayo Clinic and OHSU and then I
mentioned and we have our breast cancer
Consortium so this is a Consortium of
investigators uh that have gotten
together to come up with best practices
uh and different ways to visualize and
look at breast cancer tissue on the
geomex platform and so that Consortium
has now come together and and they are
publishing those best practices so we're
really excited to see some of the
results coming out of that Consortium
that we've set up around breast cancer
for the genomic system
but in regards to the Leica relationship
and this automation of our protocol and
then as I mentioned it's standard
immunohist chemistry protocols but you
can imagine you know that takes some
time and some expertise to be able to
know how to do your antigen retrieval
and we've got protocols that we can give
to folks so um you know it we we walk
you through those steps
um but it can take some time you're
talking about like about three and a
half uh three plus hours of Hands-On
time to manually you know prepare a
sample and stain it you know anyone
who's done IHC work in the past can
understand you know that that can take
some time
um and so what's nice about the
relationship with with Leica is this
ability to automate that on their bond
RX system we go from about three hours
of Hands-On time uh to about 30 minutes
of Hands-On time with the bond RX
um and and and the capabilities of that
platform to do you know things like up
to 30 slides at a single time
um really allows you to scale your work
with the geomix system as well so you
know you do your prep the day before uh
you'll do your staining overnight on the
bond you'll show up the next morning
take the samples off of the bond put
them on the geomix system scan those
slides select your regions of interest
uh tell the system to run it'll go and
collect by the end of the day you'll
have all of your collections done uh
that that plate will then come off of
the system you'll do an overnight
hybridization or your library prep
um to go into your sequencer that data
will come off of the sequencer it'll go
through an NGS pipeline that we've set
up there's uh either that NGS pipeline
is either loaded directly onto the
Illumina sequencer or it can be uh or
you can run it through your own computer
system that you've got in your lab and
we've we've got the NGS pipeline that
can be loaded directly onto it
um those uh that those data is that fast
key file gets converted into a DCC file
and then that DCC file gets loaded back
into the software for your data analysis
so you know all said and done it's about
a five day protocol with very minimum
Hands-On time mostly automated through
there
um but gives you really great Multiplex
quantitative data and obviously can be
done in a Serial manner so that you can
constantly have data coming out of this
platform so if you really want to scale
up your operations having it automated
with Leica and then being able to kind
of serialize the work that you're doing
can really scale the amount of data that
can be generated on this system
so with that said just to summarize
everything the geomix platform is
extremely flexible uh it's the highest
Plex most sensitive system out there on
the market today for doing this type of
hyplex spatial analysis
um it gives you the ability to detect
all the targets you're interested in so
like I said anything from 10 up to you
know 20 000 plus genes or proteins at a
time
um it is multiomic so we can do both
protein and mRNA detection uh you can
explore any region that you're
interested in so it allows you to ask
very specific questions or in the case
of doing things like gridding you can
just you know look to see where the data
drives you so it's totally up to you
gives you that flexibility for for
selecting different regions of your
tissue and then it also allows you to
work with any samples that are available
to you as well so whether they be ffpe
or fresh frozen or as I mentioned corn
needle biopsies or tissue microarrays or
whole Mount sections and then you know
Nana strings got this reputation of
being a good high quality uh building
good high quality platforms
um that's our Legacy with our encounter
system and it continues on with our
geomix platform and any future platforms
that we develop is our quality system
um and so you can you can trust the data
that comes off of this right it's proven
it's optimized and it's automated so you
get great reproducibility great
reproducibility between users and
multi-sites and multi-systems
um and so that allows you to once again
think about scaling that data and using
it in your large translational studies
so with that said uh that concludes my
presentation and uh looking forward to
any questions that anyone might have
thank you
well thank you so much Nick for that
informative presentation
reminder to our audience on how to
submit questions simply type them into
the Q a box and click on the send button
we will answer as many questions as we
have time for
and let's see the first question is
um let's see is this technology
currently available for purchase or
through a cro
that's right yeah thank you so uh you
can purchase our geomix system it is
available for purchase it's on the
market today we launched it back in 2019
um and so if you're looking to adopt
technology
um certainly you can reach out uh to
your nanostring representative and we
can get you some pricing or if you're
looking to just test it out we've got
some abilities to go out there and test
the technology as well but we also have
service providers so there's a network
of service providers globally that offer
a geomex as a service they are both
academic and Industry service providers
so a number of cross as well as core
facilities and academic centers so yeah
please feel free to reach out to Nana
string if you're interested in testing
it we'd be happy to uh connect you with
the right path
great and it looks like our second
question is how many genes can be
transcription
yeah so the whole transcriptome assay
um Can profile up to 22 right now up to
22 000 genes at a single time it does
have the ability to add customization as
well
um but yes both the human and mouth
whole transcriptome assays
um are up to about 22 000 genes that's
the entire protein encoding
transcriptome and both can include
customization
great and it looks like this is our last
seated question unless we have some more
that are coming in
the last one how does this technology
compare to other array-based or Imaging
based platforms on the market yeah thank
you so uh there are a number of spatial
genomics platforms out there today and
it's a very hot Market obviously we were
one of the first uh into it with our
geomix system
um and uh and so you know we're pretty
unique in our approach for doing
profiling spatially and that's because
we have that digital micro mirror
capability that allows us to unselect
regions of interest for profiling but
then also to be able to Contour those
regions specifically specifically to the
biology that you're interested in so
those examples that I gave looking at
tumor versus stroma the geomic system
because it's not kind of randomly
gridded on there it's kind of in its own
Smart Way allows you to select that
biology and profile it independently as
opposed to like an array-based
technology where you're kind of limited
to whatever Falls within that gridded
area and then for the Imaging platforms
you know we already developing our own
Imaging system Multiplex Imaging system
as well which we've recently announced
but we do see these as very
complementary so Imaging and profiling
to be very complementary on the Imaging
side you're going to be limited in Plex
and that's going to always be the case
because it's always going to be
fluorescently based so flexing you know
to go to higher and higher Plex is going
to take more and more time and
eventually you kind of hit a saturating
limit there where with profiling the way
we do it with our oligo tags you know we
can go up to whole transcriptome and
Beyond theoretically there is no limit
to the number of Plex that we can do so
you know between profiling and imaging
profiler is usually at the whole
transcriptome level or Beyond imagers
usually more targeted even if it's a
high Plex
um multiplexed Imaging assay it's still
fairly targeted as compared to what you
can do with like a platform like geomix
and then the quantitative you know
aspect of it higher throughput more
quantitative those are usually the big
differentiators between a profiler and
an Imager
oh great fantastic do you have any
closing comments for today Nick
no I mean I think um you know this is an
area that's continuing to evolve the
spatial biology market and world and uh
you know we're here to help guide that
Evolution as best as we can with our
tools and Technologies
um so if you have any questions if
you're interested in trying out the
platform if you have a great idea for a
project you know we do a number of
different grants throughout the year
um so there should be no limit right I
mean if you're if you're interested in
running a study please reach out to us
and we will find a way to work with you
right now it's our goal to really kind
of democratize you know spatial biology
and so uh we will find a way whether
that's through you know the acquisition
of the technology itself or through a
service provider or even through like
our own internal Labs you know we would
love to work with you so please reach
out uh and looking forward to more uh
Partnerships and opportunities to work
with the Leica team as well
well fantastic again a big thank you to
you Nick and thank you to our audience
for joining us today and for their
interesting questions
um we will address any questions we did
not have time for today and that's
submitted during our on-demand period
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration this session
webcast will also be on demand after the
event
see that's all for this session and
thank you for joining us we hope you
have enjoyed this presentation bye for
now